[Music]
before we get started i just want to
mention that only 20.8 percent of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
content please subscribe to support the
channel hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing voldemort and his horcruxes a
known proponent of dark magic tom riddle
was a troubled young boy who began
experimenting with the dark arts at an
extremely young age as he grew older and
older tom riddle who had been born with
an inability to feel certain emotions
grew hungry for power fueled by the
spite that he felt towards his parentage
and a world that he felt rejected him
right from the start dumbledore first
encounters riddle at wool's orphanage in
1938 and it's on this visit the
dumbledore informs riddle of his magical
background
riddle knew that he was different but he
didn't know what he was he had no sense
of identity however that certainly
didn't stop him from tormenting all of
the other orphans as the years passed
riddle underwent a lot of change first
he got into darker and darker forms of
magic and later he decided to get rid of
his filthy muggle name from that point
onward going by a name that would strike
fear into the hearts of wizard kind
voldemort today's video is going to look
at one particular piece of dark magic
that voldemort produced in his lifetime
the horcrux wickedest of magical
inventions while studying at hogwarts
tom riddle befriended horace slughorn
his then potions professor
slughorn had a reputation for choosing
favorites and tom who demonstrated an
unparalleled ability to learn and
uncanny ability to perform magic became
one of these favorites however it was
this relationship that led to slughorn
revealing pivotal information about
horcruxes to riddle a horcrux is an
object in which a dark witch or wizard
has imbued part of their soul the
ultimate purpose of creating a horcrux
is to achieve immortality however the
truly sinister component of creating a
horcrux is that in order to produce one
you must murder someone there are only
two known wizards who have created a
horcrux the first being herpo the fowl
and the second being voldemort who
produced many in fact voldemort ended up
creating seven anyway without further
ado let's dive into voldemort's
horcruxes where i'll be ranking them
from least to most effective at least in
my opinion bear in mind this list will
not be in order of creation
7. rowena ravenclaw's diadem rowena
ravenclaw was of course one of the
founders of hogwarts and her daughter
helena aka the grey lady was the one
that voldemort manipulated in order to
find the diadem helena was among the
first generations of hogwarts students
and began attending the school while her
mother rowena along with the other three
founders were at the school however just
a few years into her magical education
helena stole her mother's diadem
believing that it could make her more
powerful still in conflict with her
mother helena later died after she was
stabbed by the bloody baron but she did
remain at hogwarts as a ghost voldemort
used his talent for manipulation on
helena having her believe that he
understood her anguish this led to her
revealing the location of her mother's
diadem which was hidden in albania in
order to turn the diadem into a horcrux
voldemort killed an unnamed albanian
peasant after creating this horcrux
voldemort travelled to hogwarts to
inquire about teaching at the school and
it was at this time that he hid the
diadem in the room of requirement so why
is this horcrux so low down on the list
well it just didn't have much of an
impact on the story i mean it's
certainly an interesting aspect to the
story but the diadem didn't kill anyone
or make anyone go mad it was rather
anticlimactically destroyed by vincent
crabbe it was also hidden in a pretty
bad location if you ask me
6. helga hufflepuff's cup helga
hufflepuff was one of the four hogwarts
founders and a cup which was one of her
prized possessions was targeted by
voldemort because of its association
with her voldemort held these objects in
high praise because of who they belonged
to powerful witches and wizards per
pottermore this cup was handed down
through hufflepuff's descendants until
it reached hebseiba smith the ageing
which took a shine to a young
borgenenburg's clerk treating him to a
glimpse of her most treasured belongings
two days later pepsible was dead and her
house elf hokie seemed to remember
poisoning her mistresses coco the cup
and locket had both vanished this is of
course the point at which voldemort
turned the cup into a horcrux killing
hepsiba by spiking her cocoa with poison
the cup was then stored in bellatrix the
stranger's vault who kept it at
gringotts the cup was reasonably well
protected but gringotts is probably not
the best place for things like that
because it's almost the obvious place
you'd go in search of important items in
terms of effectiveness i'd say that
hufflepuff's cup under arena ravenclaw's
item were way below the others 5.
salazar's the lorenz locket the next
horcrux i want to discuss is salazar's
the durin's locket which was created
after voldemort murdered a muggle
the locket made its way into circulation
within the wizarding world when merapi
voldemort's mother pawned the locket out
of desperation
this is how hep seba smith the same
witch who had hufflepuff's cup came into
its possession when voldemort killed
hepsiba he scored a two two-for-one and
got the locket as well
after killing a helpless muggle
voldemort hid the locket in a cave
protected by all sorts of dark magic
including in ferry
interestingly enough however the
defenses of the cave were breached on
numerous occasions
first by creature and regulus black next
by harry and dumbledore who retrieved a
decoy the locket however was still quite
a problem for harry and the gang mainly
because they had to carry it around for
so long unaware of how to destroy it it
mainly affected ron who wore it the most
and it ultimately led to separation
jealousy and anger among the trio
four tom riddle's diary tom riddle's
diary dates all the way back to
voldemort's younger years when he was
still a student at hogwarts it was a
blank diary but what no one knew was
that this unassuming object had been
turned into a horcrux by voldemort after
killing myrtle warren aka moaning myrtle
in 1943
myrtle spent her last moments staring
into the eyes of the basilisk that came
from slytherin's chamber of secrets
before his first downfall voldemort gave
the diary to lucius malfoy for safe
keeping however it wasn't long before
lucius smuggled the diary back into
hogwarts where it could wreak havoc
the diary had a profound impact on ginny
weasley who used the diary as well a
diary confiding in it and scribbling her
emotions and feelings onto all of its
pages ginny poured out her soul to me
and her soul happened to be exactly what
i wanted i grew stronger and stronger on
a diet of her deepest fears her darkest
secrets the diary was effective because
it allowed voldemort to grow stronger
manipulated ginny and very nearly killed
harry
3. marvolo gaunt spring the next horcrux
i want to discuss is marvolo gauntering
an heirloom of the gaunt family which
was of course voldemort's mother's side
as voldemort was an orphan he later
became obsessed with his family history
which led to him traveling to little
hangalton where he met morphin gaunt his
uncle who was wearing the ring voldemort
then stole the ring bewitched morphin
and traveled to the home of his father
tom riddle senior where he promptly
killed him turning the ring into a
horcrux this horcrux was effective
because of the impact that it had on the
story you see when dumbledore destroyed
it he fell ill he was cursed and though
he was killed by a nevada cadaver sent
from snape dumbledore would have died
anyway 2. nagini up next we have nagini
voldemort's trusty companion and the
snake that was once a woman the victim
of a vicious maledictus curse it
speculated that nagini and voldemort
first met in the forest of albania
sometime in the 1980s at this point
nagini would have likely fully assumed
her snake-like form and voldemort would
have been hiding in his disembodied
state at this point in time both nagini
and voldemort were a bit lost in the
world nagini was stuck in a snake form
facing an entirely new identity and
voldemort had been recently defeated
for this reason i think it's only
natural that the pair teamed up nagini
became instrumental in lord voldemort's
survival before he could be restored to
his real body and her venom was even
used as an elixir that helped him to
survive it was one of the primary
ingredients in a potion that he used to
rebuild his strength nagini also helped
voldemort to commit numerous murders and
one murder in particular the murder of
bertha jorkins sealed their bond more
than ever you see after the death of
bertha jorkins nagini became one of
voldemort's horcraxes she was now more
than just the companion of voldemort a
fragment of voldemort's soul lived
inside of her the havoc that she wrought
before her death at the hands of neville
longbottom certainly makes her deserving
of this spot on her list she was
essential to voldemort though i do think
that it would have made a lot more sense
for her to have completely avoided the
battle of hogwarts
1. harry potter harry's not actually a
proper horcrux but nonetheless a piece
of ultimate soul fragment lived inside
of him in my eyes harry was the ultimate
horcrux because for the longest time no
one even knew that harry was one in
order for voldemort to die harry would
need to die as well
harry ultimately chose to sacrifice
himself for the greater good knowing
that his life was linked to voldemort's
however harry of course ends up
returning to the world of the living as
the only thing that was killed was the
piece of voldemort's soul inside of him
because of the unpredictability of
having harry as a horcrux and his
inadvertent transformation into one
harry was the strongest link keeping
voldemort's soul alive
and that's it for this video do you guys
agree with my rankings let me know in
the comments section down below until
next time it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you